- If I can experiment during college,
McDonald's can experiment with flavors.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- I think it'll taste like
chocolate Oreo ice cream
with some coffee thrown in.
- I think it's gonna be a
cookie drink for adults.
- I think, like all McDonald's things,
it's going to be manufactured
and designed to like,
a seemingly fake level of perfection.
- We've got this cookie magma
kind of hanging out on top.
- It does kind of look
like it could be cement.
But I think that's just the Oreo flecks.
- It already looks too rich for me.
I would have done without
the crumbles on top.
- Oh, you gotta have the crumbles.
- Nah, nah, nah, this is a bit much.
- This is Oreos we're talking about here.
- I can taste the coffee a
bit more than I expected.
- This is an Oreo water.
- It's super sweet.
Heavy, refreshing, it's like
all things that are good.
- There's no coffee in this.
I call bull(beep).
- Some great textures going on in here.
It's like chewing good rocks.
- It's just so sweet.
The only way I can drink this is like,
you know those little
hamster water dispensers?
Where it's like doop, doop, doop, doop.
- Look, I commend McDonald's
for really pushing the
boundaries and trying stuff.
But I feel like they have a
long history of doing things
that they don't need to do.
- If they're gonna serve
this for breakfast,
then I want breakfast
twenty-four hours at McDonald's.
- This has got "hit" written all over it.
- What about some alcohol?
- Yeah, put some alcohol in there.
Put some rum in there.
- McDonald's after dark.
- They could make like a
cookies and cream, that's like.
- I think that's what Oreos are.
- Oh, sh(beep).
- The secret agents at
McDonald's like snuck
into the Starbucks
laboratory and were like,
we gotta get all the frappe.
Let's get all the frappe recipes.
And then like, the cops came
and they only got half the recipe.